hello welcome to the Lobby gamespot's
weekly hang out every Tuesday at 2 p.m.
Pacific right here on gamespot.com um
I'm very happy to be back in my seat and
we have a bunch of great games coming
out uh this week and the next couple of
months I feel like video games are back
after a slow summer uh Colin Kaepernick
is going to come on the C no I'm sorry
Eric Tay is going to come on to do his
best Colin Kaepernick impression with
NFL 15 we've got Infamous Second Son
first slide third strike the first
DLC thank you uh for Infamous Second Son
on the PlayStation 4 I'm going to check
that one out but first of all I am
delighted to be joined by Mr Michael
McMain from zav will make favorite
interviews from E3 well thank you for
that the Creator my favorite interview
as well oh was it really yes okay let's
try to do it again Chris Waters and
Kevin vanard here as well of course
we're going to we're going to make it
the best interview ever for lichdom
battle mage or as uh Chris and the rest
of our colleagues like to call it LOM
batage this this game it's out today it
is like officially no more Alpha no more
beta play the whole thing uh how does
that feel you guys have been working on
this for quite a while yeah it's a big
deal we're all kind of freaking out a
little bit H before we talk about the
game I want to briefly touch on kind of
your story because I that's we talked
right before E3 about correct like how
many games you'd worked on I assumed
that You' worked on a bunch of games
because this is seems to be a game
that's quite mechanically deep and
whatnot but this is your first game this
is Xavier's first game right that is
correct yes it's our first game for the
studio and the first game for me as well
so you used to work in a totally
different industry and then kind of
decided you wanted to make a game about
badass Mages yeah I mean we were in a
position where I had an engineering team
that I could kind of do whatever I
wanted I saidwell I've always I'm an
avid gamer I always want to play games
so I'm going to make one that's what we
did is that like a daunting experience
like coming from it was to be honest it
was a little sobering I think in the
beginning um you know it we knew that we
needed to get some experts at it Shi
games before but uh but it was a there
was definitely a labor of love involved
in this it uh you know it took us a
while to get going and figure out what
we were going to do we spent some time
prototyping and started on this about
two years ago and uh this is our our
first thing and we feel good about it
fantastic we're all excited let's hop
right in h Kevin you played it a bunch
of times on the on the the lobby I've
been on the lobby before playing the
game and I'm I'm gonna be I'm sure I'll
be terrible it's it's it's it's it's
just the given the developer here so
this means I'm going to look as bad as
possible your attitude is terrible it's
it's it's the thing I do come on Kevin
chin up you got this luckily I don't
need the health The Shield so I'm just
going to go right on first of all this
is uh obviously I think this game makes
a really great first impression it looks
gorgeous uh this is cry cry engine right
yes it is that's correct and this is
actually a fairly tough area to get
through where you're at right here right
Kevin always picks the toughest
areas what are these gross blocks of Goo
that you're making oh you got frozen
it's my least favorite thing to happen
that's that uh bone Bolter he's probably
going to shoot you again while you stare
at that so L Bal Mage is a first person
game where you play as a mage but you
guys have kind of I guess because you're
only playing as Mage you're not like
doubling up with every anyone else the
mage's role within battle has kind of
has changed you guys have gotten rid of
cooldowns and whatnot that's correct you
know we just wanted to do something that
really highlights magic and we started
by taking away some of the you know the
things that typically get uh constraints
that are put on Magic right where you've
got cooldowns and Mana bars and things
and just make it all about just throwing
your power around as much as you can um
and I'm stinking already but this is a
particularly tough area I have to say it
is so you got your corruption going now
that's cool I really love corruption
it's my favorite thing because oh God
damn generally gosh I told you I was
going to
stay the neat thing about corruption is
um it's about infecting your enemy with
parasites and so depending on how you
build your your spell there's three
different ways to build every spell
you've got destruction which is about
doing damage or control which is
typically about uh you know crowd
controlling an enemy and then um you've
got Mastery which is about debuffing
them so you get really huge big big
crits on them I say I love that getting
frozen screen because it's not like oh
the edges of my vision are blue like no
your eyeballs are straight up frozen
over you can't see
crap and L is a from my experience
playing it and also from watching Kevin
suck real hard on the lobby H it's a
challenging first person game it is
surprisingly challenging I just sorry I
I didn't mean to interrupt it I wasn't
really expecting the challenge that it
became I want to remind the folks at
home if they have any questions uh for
hopefully for Michael because I feel
like Kevin's got his uh he's busy enough
here by all means put them in the twist
shot um I'll be I'll be pull them
pulling them out of there so that guy is
the guy that was freezing you
primarily when you see those bone
bolters with the blue mhm that means
that their shots are frozen shots uh can
we talk a little bit about the the sort
of um spell creation tool kit cuz I
found this really interesting at E3 yeah
um instead of there being like straight
up just a bunch of trees that you kind
of pull from and pour experience into
you guys have went a little bit deeper
on your spell creation yeah what we did
is we made it so that um instead of
dropping spells that are pre-made or or
upgrades that are pre-made it's all
about dropping the components that you
want to use to build your own spells
right to build them the way that you
want to build them so you've got uh the
basic shape of the spell which is
determines how you're going to deliver
it right like this like a fire this is a
what we call a missile spell so it
actually has a little bit of a homing
and uh and then there's other different
targeted shapes like a lob that has no
aiming component throws us a lob and
breaks into other things or whatever yes
and then there's a a beam there's a
couple of different AOE and so forth so
you take that shape and then you take
these other components that are called
augments that come in the form of
Destruction control and Mastery and
those determine how your spell is going
to behave that must have been crazy for
you guys to sort of uh bug test because
presumably there's quite a lot of
variation that can happen there yes yeah
there is quite a number of different uh
different things cuz there's eight
sigils in the game and there's seven
different ways to shape them and then
you've got three different ways to build
each shape so it can get uh out of hand
I got a first question to here from
Hassan in the twitch chat is there a
story in this game there is um we have a
a story you basically are playing uh an
individual who the sort of nobility the
dark nobility of of the town has put
them under your boot and uh you become
freed by some uh uh an older Mage that
gives you these bracers of power to let
you exact revenge and then kind of fight
for the good of the city so went in uh
went pretty deep with voice acting as
well in this B boy did yeah we have Troy
Baker and uh Jennifer hail and Clancy
Brown and uh and some others is that
presumably a lot of the stuff that
people who has on the Early Access cuz
this has been in in I guess Alpha and
well beta presumably mostly uh for quite
a while now um is that mostly what's
come out in the full release the sort
the story is now one straight yeah now
that we have the whole story in there um
we've had bits and pieces that have come
online as we as we came online with our
different uh stages of the game and um
we've got uh We've added quite a bit of
depth to that to the story so shall we
do I thought I'd show the the bit so one
one good place to start obviously is
synthesis because you can
take you you keep upgrading these things
like you start with just like white
white things and uh you you gradually
combine those and they become more
powerful then you start combining those
and they become more powerful and
there's a there's a certain element
where it's like H I wonder what this is
going to make when I put these all
together and and uh so we can start with
something like uh like just combining
these
three are you expecting and boom now we
have a dis a dissolving destruction of
precision it's hard to read the TV but
like so then you get multipliers and and
yes you get increased apocalyptical
there that's pretty cool another neat
thing if you look at the synthesis if
you go up to one of the blue ones you
have there oh yeah you'll see that
there's uh go down one to that that
Harden Shield the one Higher which one
here oh here yeah that that there's two
there's actually two synthesis options
on that so you can synthesize that from
purple to Orange so you can go up twice
on that one have you had your community
sort of almost having like like cookbook
battles where they were creating like
different spells and sharing them within
the forms and whatnot
right have you considered a sequel to
the game called cookbook
battles this is why I don't make video
games yes uh hgp one is asking about the
story um is is it linear is it open um
how long is it St like that so the
approach that we took to the level
design is it's they're tailored levels
you have a beginning and an end to each
level that you go through they're
they're crafted in that sense um some of
the later levels have some more
exploration areas where they kind of
open up and you have different paths
that you can take um but it's it's a uh
we have a sort of a beginning to end
approach to the game are you guys going
to be um adding more to it over the next
coming months and years is this a we
haven't we haven't announced any
upcoming stuff yet but uh we we're
definitely not done with be a little bit
fun funny to spend so much time engaging
with your community and adding stuff and
then suddenly just to cut it off EXA
exactly that's been a big thing for us
just the The Early Access has been
phenomenal for us it really helped hone
the game this is a completely different
game just uh 12 weeks ago really yes it
looked very very different back then do
you imagine that'll continue to be the
case you'll probably tweak and whatnot
mhm how do you choose what time to
release it so we had decided that we
knew that two years ago yeah when we sat
down we we had this date set
based on the date as opposed to yeah we
were we were shooting for the date cuz
you know when you go to release a game
it's we don't have a publisher right
this is this is just something that
we're doing on our own and it's easy to
just keep going forever yeah you have to
pick a date and then and release it and
so that's what we did is that something
you've taken from your was a nice BL is
that a sort of a mentality you've taken
from your your your previous job sort of
applying into yeah you have to have you
have to have a constraint that you're
operating
under uh King of the den 91 asks can you
customize your gear so outside of the
spell stuff uh in terms of items and
whatnot or is that more of a Warrior
game thing yeah that so for us it's all
about your magic and innate power so
everything that's dropping is your
spells and your defense there are no
bracers or stabs or robes or anything
like that it's all in your magic uh a
lot of questions in the chat asking I'm
going to go with Bob Jones 1980 uh what
platform this is on so this is out on
Steam today on PC that's correct um you
guys looking at consoles at all for this
bad boy so you know I'd love to see this
on a console we don't have any specific
plans for that yet but uh I would
definitely love to see that watch this
space H Obama Dan asks great name uh
does it have multiplayer any Co-op any
competitive no right now it's a single
player
experience going to kill me you right
how you doing Kevin here do it do it
take it take it do it quick there you
go Kevin talk a little bit about how
your sort of what what your tactics here
on combat cuz so it depends on what I'm
facing um sometimes there's just there's
just a good old fashion
you know like Serious Sam move backwards
and and do your best but that doesn't
always work and sometimes blocking is
the better thing even for me when I'm
I'm not as block heavy as I think the
game wants me to
be nice now his eyeballs are Frozen as
you see like right now I'm a little
worried about stuff like that
so oh I thought I was dead I was keeping
going one thing that I like though is
that um you get to you get to keep
everything so so death is basically just
a you know go back to the previous Point
um but you get to keep all of the things
that you got you're having trouble um
and it said ice leveled up during that
section so those those levels up they
stay with you that's correct oh yeah yes
everything so if you not only the loot
every time loot lands in your inventory
you get uh it saves the game and then oh
cool and then you you're at your sigils
level as you're doing things they have
different requirements so it might be
kill a certain number of enemies or or
that sort of thing I just zoomed right
through this before it's funny that I
specifically didn't take another route
because there's another route that's
really hard like oh I'm not going to do
that I'll look like a fool we're
obviously looking at the sort of Arctic
tundra level here uh there's a a lot of
variety as well in terms of the level
design that is correct right when you
get later in the game there's you know
there's a swamp area there's a a desert
area sort of a ruins in the desert
that's really really cool yeah you can
see all that sort of stuff stuff on um
gamespot's own coverage and also on on
the steam uh page on the store Page
you've got a little trailer there as
well people can check out go right ask
is there a limited number of spells you
can create like a Max Level uh or is it
more based on you discovering the sigils
and the yeah so we are our our loot
drops in tiers and as you go through the
game the tier uh continually increases
and we go pretty deep in the tiers in
our new game plus we have a new game
plus experience at after you complete
the story we kind of chain pieces
together okay so you do these little
uh different types of missions as you go
through facing different types of uh
enemies do you expect people to uh to do
that to sort of take the character that
they've had or do you think people will
sort of start from the start and re spe
so we really kind of have you know the
an option to do both if you want to
start over again and play something you
haven't played you can do that um you
have access to all the sigils but the
way the leveling works you can only
level three of them okay so if you
decide to level a fourth you have to
turn one of the other three off and you
lose all your levels in so um so there's
a you know a choice to make is there any
add desk to respecing like Das do you
lose any of your XP when you Respec or
you allow to move around yeah it's it
it's all based on tasks that are like
Kill 30 enemies kill 80 enemies so you
lose that that progress and you have to
go through that again if you decide to
let's let's upgrade the sigil my
favorite thing about doing these um uh
my favorite thing about some you just
get the menu you just got SM the game
doesn't pause when you go into the menu
it only pauses when you go into the
system menu that's
correct yeah noing your spells in the
middle of see I saw this coming I saw
this
coming the good news is that the worst
ever yeah the good news is that most of
the I don't know I don't know like I I'm
actually starting to sort of enjoy this
this
challenge because I like having to learn
new ways of of dealing with it the the
first boss it was interesting like the
first the first point where it was where
it really was hard for me is the very
first boss um and it took a little bit
of doing because it's one of those
bosses where it's just not like okay
you're not just dealing with big dude
you're dealing with a bunch of ads too
minions and you just come from playing
quite a lot of divinity so it's almost
like I did that's that's a different
kind of hard but one of my favorite
things about doing a game where people
are are interested in it is that the
questions coming through are so specific
I'm going to go real quick one word
answers on this two may ask any pet
system pet system yes okay any puzzles
like side quests outside of the main
combat slender no any uh is there a lava
level a lava level there is lava in a
level yes great
okay technically like it watch out for
the Bowman Kevin oh I always forget
about the Bowman thank you there's and
there's two of them I I think I got the
one though excellent uh all right Kevin
you kill this dude or die I thought I
was a
if you kill guys control so now you got
to pop them with your fire
I telling you what to
do the number one expert on Lum battage
is sitting right beside
you cool thing there as soon as you kill
him oh he kills you he's so fast but
it's funny cuz I really like I never
like there was a while if I go through
that other area I'll swear sorry I got
so excited I'm spitting all over the
developer um if I go through the other
area I will start swearing because I'm
not like I like I like using freedom of
movement while I play it and it's it's a
little bit more confined so you have to
be very careful like you get three guys
coming on you at once and you have to
kind of get in in in position so that
you can see all three of them at one
time because if you don't maneuver right
you've got dudes you can't see attacking
you that never goes well in this game
are you doing the review yeah I'm
working on it now when will it be up
yeah I don't know because I don't know
how long it's gonna be but I'm told it's
it's quite a bit longer than where I'm
at yes you got a bit to go through so uh
but I've I've I'm enjoying it so far and
I enjoyed it in Alpha and beta and it's
it's really good to get back to it and
there's been a lot done I mean he's
right I mean just for my perspective
like that there's a lot of stuff that's
difference between night and day like
this whole interface all new like all of
that is different just from the last
time I played it so cool so yes review
soon on gamespot.com Micha thank you so
much for coming in you guys have come
over obviously all the way from Georgia
to the West Coast but you're not just
staying here you're heading up to packs
yeah we're going to be at packs we have
a big booth there so come by and see us
at packs excellent L on battle mage out
today on Steam H we're actually giving
away a bunch of copies uh we're also
giving away along with that a bunch of
copies to Plants versus Zombies which is
now on PlayStation 4 and PS3 so if you
want to win any of those take your pick
uh all you have to do is follow Gamespot
on Twitter and uh use # GS the lobby and
let us know which game you want and also
which platform Lich them again just to
remind you is just on the personal
computer all right we got a bunch more
games to hop into NFL it's going to Rand
out the show and we're going to talk a
little about what we're doing at packs
but first of all we're going to check
out Infamous Second Son last slide third
strike HD Remix Metro last life Infamous
it's like a it's it's Metro but in
Seattle right after this
trailer
master
hawen name either of those two Pokemon
that were fighting is one of them
trubbish nope Kevin is there a Pokemon
named trouish yes I don't play Pokemon I
don't know it's the garbage Pokemon it
is garbor is its uh is it yeah I swear
to God swear to God I think it was
Machamp and Lucario but I don't really
those are outside like 150 the original
151 I'm okay with get a bit outside of
that not no what's the keychain one
called again clef key or something uh
sure keychain
yes there is I swear to God yeah that's
true no I can't tell if you're if you
are think I'm being sarcastic or I know
that there that that exists and I
believe you do you know about the one
that's an ice cream cone why are we
showing Infamous we're not doing the
infamous bit yet that's just Kevin we're
talking about playing I'm sorry I'm
sorry Pokemon fans it's okay do you know
what the ice cream one's called no you
made it up Vil it's called Vil no Vil
that is a character in Final Fantasy
fantasy got Skeleton Crew back there and
you're a boss and you run this whole
goddamn thing with Eric some a picture
of the Ice Cream Pokemon I'd really
appreciate it I will eat ice cream if
that happens maybe at the end of this
infamous second s first light last Light
HD Remix a bit I challenge you to say
the name of this game title correctly
I'll do right now in the intro which we
will cut to on the video on demand
version yes welcome back we're here
PlayStation 4 Kev vanord is with us to
play Infamous Second Son first light hi
you're playing that girl who I met in
when I played fetch is this whole game
fetch Quest hey oh I see what you did
there was terrible you got to do it
though what can okay so here's my
favorite thing to do in the game
actually this is singularity this is
like your super duper uer
power there it is there it is a
singularity no context for anyone
watching the video on demand version
that's just a little live magic favorite
that bit there if you just wanted to
watch the infamous stuff this is why you
should watch the lobby cuz we're so
organized cuz you would have gotten that
joke you were playing as fetch here I
see I am playing as fetch here this is
uh oh my goodness you're just lighting
up that parked car oh take this people
parked calmly in your car oh I guess
they were so that's how you stop a stop
a driveby is you kill everybody in the
area driveby done God Dam it there's no
driveby here just a bunch of terribly
burned bodies that's right so this is
post you're welcome Seattle this is post
story here um and I'm glad I get to play
this now because as bad as I was at Li
battle Maja um the good news with this
is Infamous first light is so incredibly
easy that now I can look amazing wasn't
second sun easy as well though is this
easier this is easyer in my opinion so
this is a standalone expansion right yes
it's like it's kind of like what Far Cry
blood dragon Wass to Far Cry 3 you don't
necessarily need to own uh well you
don't need to own uh infamous Second Son
to play this but uh you're playing as
fetch who is a character that you meet
uh in the uh in the the main game what
what's going on here what's what's
what's new what's different are we just
talking more of the same levels well
she's got uh she's got her own uh
upgrade system oops wrong button
sorry what Buton did you press the stand
in one place button press the touchpad
there you go there we
go cool it doesn't like any of my button
presses what is going on oh well so yes
she's got only Neon Powers oh you just
got bomb okay so in Infamous obious you
could you you had your default power at
the start so she's the one who teaches
who teaches Delson teaches is a strong
words well yeah you steal it from her oh
do you steal it from her steal it from
her right straight up Robble Robble
joint I think so you you Hamburg it from
her Kevin doesn't care Kevin's going M
he's just going to you do sort of
Hamburglar it from her but in here this
is all her stuff so so it starts with
you know like a little bit of her
backstory and and uh her brother and
it's interesting because part of part of
how they they deal with the story is a
little bit different from how it was
described in second s so it there's a
little bit less of the I'm a you know
I'm a drug dealer I'm a druggie out for
Revenge kind of thing and they try to
give it some more context make her a
little more humanized I guess okay well
outside of the story because Infamous
was a very mechanic it was a very video
game ass video game it was a video gy
video game so is this very video gamey
too are you this very video gamey yes
show me your map show me how video game
it is okay cuz Infamous is what I liked
about Infamous as well but it's you know
basically the entire game is you were
just going from District to district and
video G the crap out of so yeah that's
what it is except here this is post game
I've done all of the side things so this
stuff is just stuff that appears so was
it similar where they were they were you
taking down those big um yeah it's
similar but it's very it's much more
limited than in second sun like you only
you stop the drive buys you rescue some
hostages if you want um you you collect
shards by doing the whole like you'll
see like when I when I now go into light
speed now you've got these uh little you
know like vortexes to go through these
are basically arrows on the ground in
Mario Kart exactly exactly right but the
other the other big thing is the is the
challenge Arenas okay and uh I'll go
into a challenge Arena and kind of show
you what that's about
so I'll
do survival so you get to play if you've
already finished um if you've already
played second sun then you get access to
using Delson and these as well okay um
so if you don't own second sun so if you
don't if you don't own second sun that
you don't get access to Delson but
that's not a huge deal but there's it's
interesting here so this is this is uh
sort of the battle you know this is the
battle arena this is is this a wave
based it is wave based um what you I
think it was he said it was survival I
know and there's another one where you
also have to uh where you also have to
rescue hostages
Okay Kevin sell me on in from his second
on first life because right now it seems
like it's pretty limited it's pretty
limited um all things considered the one
the one thing that I liked at first was
the challenge stuff because you're like
you're moving around you're doing cool
stuff um you you know you get to you
know you get to shoot guys and then you
have cool enemies in the in the Arenas
when they start coming out that are all
demonic and cool like flying things and
and stuff like that kind of but then
after a while what you discover is is
that once you unlock fully unlock your
uh I'll show you I'm trying going to try
to get to a good spot once you fully
unlock your homing missiles yeah um dup
dainy hoodie it's just yes I do it's
just easy mode that's like saying I I I
was atan Bay and all I got was this t-
well you're you're right now you're I
just like that the prison system is
giving out hoodies and not just like
some button- up jackets branded slave
hoodies but that's the thing right now
that's how this game is set up is that
you are you are showing off your powers
um to to what's her face Miss evil okay
spoilers the concrete Maiden that's how
you killed her at the end I assumed you
did so so that's what's happening like
the whole the story itself is told as a
flashback like you've already you've
already been captured for the most part
then stuff happens after that but you
know you're telling the story as a
flashback and all of these challenge
levels are are done narratively in a way
where you're you're showing off what you
can do okay H Chris did you play
Infamous Second Son I played a bit of
Infamous Second Sun why did you stop
here we go uh it was just really I don't
know my my sort of enthusiasm for open
world run around and do all these
objective stuff is sort of been on on a
Wayne lately like I tried to get into
Black Flag last year I did a little bit
but it didn't quite catch for me I don't
really know I don't know why yeah just
you know you get these like different
sort of phases in your life with your
gaming at least I do where I like have
an appetite for a certain kind of game
that like now I'm really into like
playing some civilization again but like
you know not not so much the open World
stuff but yeah I don't know I did get to
interview uh the voice actress at E3 who
plays fetch Laura Bailey she's great
she's also super prolific she's like the
voice of Chun Lee oh really in all
modern Street Fighter games she was in
she was like lady comto in BioShock
Infinite she's a big character in DBZ
like tons of anime um so yeah I mean I I
got to play around with it and it was
kind of fun but it
just the combat didn't really click with
me in terms of like this is really
really satisfying this is something that
I get inherent pleasure from I think I
really got I I feel the exact same way
about when I play Black Flag and and I
think the reason I got into this is that
I was sick for like three or four days
and I needed something to just sponge
into yeah um and this was this was
perfect I was about to say the head shot
stuff was the thing that got me into the
combat in this game Slow Down slow down
and you you see there just spamming you
know it's not you know there's that bit
of skill involved in it as opposed to
like or like when you're doing the the
bits on the legs when you throw the the
the grenades like the powers you
unlocked and stuff were you know varied
in a way that at least kept you
I feel like it was distracting me a lot
like it kept every time I get a little
bit bored I'd unlock a new power and
then I was back on board around with
yeah yeah is this you you played you
completed second sun yeah I completed
second sun what you got on this so far
are you reviewing this I did it's up now
actually I I you know I I it's okay I
gave it a six um it's it's okay but gosh
darn it there we go but like you'll see
like I I don't mind necessarily that a
game is easy but what kills me about
this is like this is a chat this is a
challenge level right so you sort of
expect that there's a reason to go but
you can easily once you upgrade your
homing missile thing um in particular
you can easily Sleepwalk your way
through this to Diamond level and far
beyond like there I got to the point
where I just stopped playing certain
challenges because I would I would have
three million points and I would be well
passed I would be 45 minutes in and I
you know it's just like okay I'm
and it's still really easy and so I mean
it gets harder obviously but I just got
to the point where it's like this is
getting tedious I can do this one spammy
technique and so therefore I don't I
don't feel like if I'm comparing myself
on the leaderboards which you can do it
just sort of felt like there's it's not
really a meaning meaningful comparison
to me because I don't feel like we're
comparing how good we are I feel like
we're comparing how quickly we learned
that you can spam certain techniques or
how much time you were willing to spend
continuing to do it yeah totally and the
story stuff how long is that did you
spend most your time do I you just do
story probably two hours oh wow okay
maybe um is it $15 uh Standalone I could
be wrong somebody correct me if I'm
wrong they will that's what the internet
is for correcting our work our shy
work but I mean I like it well enough I
just think that um you know all things
considered there's no morality system um
somebody said to me on on on on Twitter
this morning well of course there's no
morality system she's she's out on a
Revenge quest to you know be mad at uh
drug dealers that that ruined her and
and her relationship with her brothers
brother's life but they actually rcom
the story a little bit um to the point
where it it it she doesn't have a
brother and she doesn't she still has a
brother she still on drugs and drugs are
great the circum the circumstances of
his death as described in Second Son are
are are differently described are shown
here it's weird because she got her
powers from a crystal meth addiction
that's the whole story of the well they
don't they don't they don't get rid of
it I mean that that aspect of the story
is still she turns into a super human
and that's the mar of the
story is if you take meth you too could
be a superhero not even once but if you
do it once maybe do it like a million
times cuz then you'll at least have
superpowers there you go I'm going to do
nobody listen to what we're saying we're
terrible terrible people H all right 6.0
on gamespot.com Kevin van I think we are
done with Infamous Second Son first life
do a single larity I I I'm doing a
single one single larity boom and goes
sweet sweet larity I like how the
singularity knows only to pull in the
guys that are bad and not you yeah and
not for the me or just anything
else is 20% it knows what's bad yeah
yeah all right Kevin vanard thank you
very much come on always I love being
here second s first light and for
playing uh L and B yeah for sucking at
battle Maja when will the review for
battle mage be up again I don't know um
because I'm still playing it but I'm
hoping in the next couple days cool
awesome all right we got a bunch of more
games to play today on the lobby and
next one up is NFL 15 Eric Tay is going
to come on uh I think he's playing me
we're going have to see I brought an
America football jersey of course sorry
pleas never do that again I call it
American football bad but first of all
we're going to have a look at a
different sport see if you can guess
which spoil it is in the 4 seconds
before the trailer starts
lacrosse
hello again everybody I'm Ernie Johnson
along with Shaquille O'Neal on 2K sports
and the NBA season is about to
begin
yeah oh
yeah
up what if I didn't get a mess going to
my head I am what I
am oh baby think
you girl I be your
man be take care
oh baby be there so my in my
sh me you can't me Su my kiss kiss me
you with this hit me you
can't give to me sweet s that M was made
to
what does it sound like when he hits one
of those threes
yakam anything else
spay how do you spell yakum y y a k k m
yakum I learned something new every
day it's that time of year again NFL 15
the 15th NFL game mad same Madden is he
still around yeah I thought they got rid
of him when they got rid of Tiger Woods
on the golf games Madden
15 are you ready for the
football football or as Europeans call
it American football my friend Eric Tay
how you doing doing all right uh very
nice of you to wear the Niners we lost
the Super Bowl Jersey you know we
discussed this the other day granted
you've been doing your halflife half
marathon uh that you were going to wear
a jersey I was and you know this would
look
you know less awkward but it's okay I
will represent there was once a show on
gamespot.com where the host wore
strictly sports jerseys and no one ever
thought it was weird it's good point it
was literally on right here yeah Rich
yeah Rich Gallop behind that wall God
Rest his soul but we're going to I guess
you're going to be the ners I like the
ners but I'm going to be a team be
fitting the ners um who should I be are
you going to try to conquer the ners are
you going to go for a conquer move I
feel like there's only other there's
only one team I can pick Steelers are 91
wow Vikings baby Vikes AP we are
definitely not all Madden you you might
want to press B you guys are definitely
choosing the exact same teams that
problem and I played as think we should
Pro should go pro I'm not going to oh
you can go rookie yeah that's good too
okay we'll go pro all right what you
think one one quarter yeah of V not 15
you could probably get two quarters in a
half get a half half Eric Tay what's
different about this year's Madden game
do the easier one what try going left ah
whatever we'll figure it out uh I think
there's a more of an emphasis on defense
now okay you're going to see uh as you
know if you guys didn't watch the stream
earlier so we're going to explain some
of these but if you did bear with me um
there's going to be some queue UPS you
know like if you're on the defensive
line you can actually like you know
press X or a it'll kind of uh trigger
for you to you know press that button
like almost like a quick Time Event yeah
and that'll help you you know do a swim
move swim move or like shed the shed The
Tackle so that you can pass rush the
quarterback mhm um and so what you're
telling me is they've changed very
specific things about this game like
last year that's always the way they do
it man got to add Little Nugget the
other thing that so we had this live
stream on earlier I was uh chatting with
a pro Madden player uh Eric problem
right and he was saying uh it's more
great it's more of a defensive based
game this year uh like he was saying
quarterbacks will now like have more
errant throws uh that don't just go to
to
opposing uh Defenders they go into space
they go somewhere else they they have a
a wider range of error so you want to be
looking at your stats for like for
different pass accuracies a little bit
more uh yeah and defense definitely a
bit of an influence this time around I
mean you got look Richard Sherman on the
cover and uh the stuff Eric was talking
about at the line and all right well
we'll see that when the game starts this
uh presentation wise looks pretty great
real good yeah yeah yeah better than
last year look at this guy sweet mock
turtlenecks hargh is Jim Harbaugh going
to be screaming his goddamn face off I
can do that I'll do it for you okay
yeah you're going to go full harb out
here yeah just kind of yell I don't have
the khakis on so you know I already made
a mistake it's not what's on your body
it's what's in your heart okay so I just
got what's in your body come and comes
out of your body in the form of anger
words oh God and maybe some spittle all
right okay like clipboards that you just
vomit out onto the field let's go
Vikings let's wi the game here we go hey
Eric does your team uh have a song that
was written by Prince no all right well
you can suck it Danny why did you choose
the Vikings H my my buddy Dale cell back
home in Ireland is a big Minnesota
Vikings fan and uh Matt Castle sucks oh
what they're putting real video of
people's faces in here and I went to
both um games in Wembley in England last
year and the one of them was the Vikings
against the Redskins and actually won it
was the second only one of two games
they won I think in the regular have won
more than two games so was your
offensive plan give ball to Adrien
Peterson and then just sit back and
watch yep I'm going to give it to Greg
James he got the team on his back though
oh man so uh I don't know if you noticed
it but like when you hiked it like it
was telling me to right trigger like
right away oh yeah yeah yeah I'll I'll
try to like we'll see if it comes up
again but did it rumble or did it just
come it rumbles it Rumbles and then it's
like if you had the reactions it'll be
like perfect or like fair right or like
poor kind of what number is great James
again 8081 right four no yeah it might
be Oh see it said late
there oh my goodness he got the team on
his back he got in there that was that
definitely wasn't I know I'm going to
say it for every single time I do
Simpson pulling it down he's got that
catching in traffic
stat bounced literally bounced off the
other guy's helmet and he held on it
that was a quite do you think i' never
played a Madden game yeah
ID three first downs in a row he is
marching come on man I'm from Ireland we
don't even this game is so far and we
refer to it with the country name
first fair enough to identify world not
over call American Madden NFL 15 exactly
I'm going to call Audible
gun double Flex you slant let's see some
hot routes up in here hot route hot
route my corner needs to follow him he's
not quick AUD shift yeah just stop stop
messing with me Mast trying to go come
on you
forgot the lay of
game he manages to hike the ball folks
what a victory here for this Vikings
offense all right oh man with that kind
of tenacity there's no way the Niners
are going to be able to stop them they
were able to hike the
ball hey it's that it's that kind of
team cohesiveness you really need to
succeed in the NFL these days pretty
sure the game knew he was talking crap
to me so you know oh really they got
real tired of it I'm so happy that your
one success was that I didn't I couldn't
hike the ball oh see it said perfect
there
oh ooh and reing the Jersey who is that
number 99 get out of my castle boy get
out of my castle
all
right what number GRE J I'm sure they
I'm sure they told me in the chat 15 15
all right now he knows who I'm going to
throw the ball I think he's going to
pass to I don't care he's in motion it's
too late he's on B oh cig
Jennings great that's that's where I
want to be good that's where I want to
be 13 baby that's the sweet spot so the
question is do you do the typical thing
or are you going to go for the you know
do oh it's a 54 y though that's pretty
far
but I got if your kicking skills are as
good as Chris's
here a 54 y might as well be a 17 yard
or a million y cuz you ain't making it
really oh sugar all right it doesn't
even look like it's going to make it
pull it back and then push it forward
when the meter goes to the top part of
the meter oh God this is I really should
have practiced this at least once oh no
you might get it way better than my that
is definitely short short all right good
way better than my earlier efforts Danny
you suck
TB all right call in and his sweet T did
they ever settle that problem where the
tattoo artists were like yo don't be
using our art in your video game I think
Colin Kaepernick Scot approved though
that's great like they I think they came
out and he's the only tattooed player in
the NFL where like 48% of players are
tattooed perhaps in this game they look
real good I don't know about you but
they look pretty good I don't know I'd
have to see a side by side they had the
same problem with CM Punk he he had the
Pepsi logo tatto oh did he why did he
have the Pepsi logo tattoed straight EDG
was that some was that some Peter Moore
action oh please catch that like in his
youth he was a spokesman for Pepsi he
tried to like make he went all in on a
Pepsi bid and it just didn't work out he
did one of those competitions where if
you get the Pepsi tattoo logo on your
hand on your arm you get a year free
worth of Pepsi do you remember that when
they when turo came out really when turo
2 or three came out they had a thing
where if you changed your name to turo
you got like
$10,000 and dude did it yeah dude's like
named no turo Smith no yeah oh my
goodness for 10 grand and it was
probably be like 10 grand before tax
that is super weird yeah if you name
your child turo will'll give you 10
grand that' be worse I like the part of
the run where Gore just went let his
body go limp on the back of another one
on the back of his blocker and did like
a little fish
wiggle he's like take me take me forward
yeah why not weird T why don't you pick
one that you don't suck so hard at come
on man Danny hit him with the fire zone
pick what that I don't suck at so much
come on look the line's right there six
why don't you listen he's just burning
he's just eating up the clock worrying
about it and let me just play I didn't
realize it was going to be a six-minute
quarter you guys should probably just
play one quarter Veron Davis oh flag
yeah no holding here cuz your whole
team's got VD V I feel like that was one
of those new defensive fouls that the
refs be calling all the time person face
masking oh why you face masking to the
face Dam it M maing me which button did
I press I'm going to accept that which
one's the fake the face masking button I
don't know so I can press it twice you
need connect you need connect for that
and then you just put your face in front
your hand in front of your uh Buddy's
face you can't see me that would be cool
what is this John Cena that would be
cool if connects like enabled ingame
like you know if you are jostling them
or like whacking their controller and it
could it would track that and then have
make in-game things happen that would be
good for the next mutant League football
game that they will definitely
leag football man that's a long time ago
mhm been a long time since the mutant
League I'm I'm not a big Madden guy but
I did play a lot of Blitz the League
Blitz was good too Blitz is pretty good
as in I only played that one where you
could shatter people's testicles though
oh the one the newer one yeah Blitz yeah
the silly one it was good fun oh no way
no way bro where am I going cutting it
back to the Midfield unorthodox to B
some negative yards there yeah I was uh
trying to style and didn't know that
that was going to do the spin backwards
I thought I was going to do a little cut
jump or jump cut look it is in an
unorthodox move he decided to run back
towards all of the guys a chance you
know third and nine for this Niner Squad
handily picked up that last third down
situation or one for one or maybe two
for two I haven't been keeping that
close
track oh psych him out psych him out
with some call some play calling oh
that's a pick oh throws into
traffic not going to happen I
really would like one of you guys to get
some points during this segment all
right let's go Vikings that's but only
in the form of a dramatic touchdown that
you do by faking this field
goal is he Faking It is he faking
it fake it or make it Dawson strong leg
Dawson that looks good and it is that's
three for the set Francisco 49ers over
the Minnesota Viking mans how we do it
it's very unexciting but we play for the
W I'm GNA kick your
ass that's my did you just onside
receive you totally onside receive yeah
I don't need I don't need a
defense all right where's the hill Mary
button you've got you got to work the
clock man you got a minute 30 left yeah
you said you want man it two quarters or
one quarter just one quarter I think one
qu this he's got a minute 32 unless you
guys want to want to extend it well see
how about if he if minut 32 is just
enough time to get two
touchdowns he's dropping back throws off
his back foot it's into the melee
there's like four Dudes in San Francisco
there how do you guys not intercept that
it was like a jump ball for free you
guys Patrick Willis all of you gentlemen
Eric Reed is this showing all of the
49ers that were closer to that pass than
the Vikings receiver pretty much they
should do that thing where they tell
where they have them say what
universities they're from and then they
make up fake universities like Ballo
Hard University Kraken Kraken Hogwarts
was probably the best one ever hey man a
Aon was that who said that name one of
his names one of the names was Aon who
was the guy who said B So Hard
University I don't remember all right
who was the guy who said his name was
Kraken and he went to Hogwarts I forget
his name how quickly our memories fade
I'm just going to Google Kraken Hogwarts
and tell
me third and 10
Danny the hopes of an entire frigid
Northern Central state in the United
States of America stand on you no way
and he's got it you see that you see
that pick you see that it's not a pick
if you're on offense I can't believe are
you talking about the receiver you I
don't know your terminology I've only
been watching the sport for like nine
months
I can't believe you see that slam dunk
three points baby oh my goodness that
was some greats that was pretty good
though on the Panthers Greg
Hardy Greg Hardy man cracking Hogwarts
oh yeah thanks sitting on it thanks yeah
you got all of that
field I hit the wrong button all right
that was as good as my spin move
negative
yards oh you just got to help Mar you
didn't see that I saw all of it you
didn't see
that oh my goodness I was afraid I was
legitimately afraid you're just throwing
terrible passes there's not one person
on the stream that doesn't hope that I
don't catch
this that's true everyone's hoping
everyone is saying Hail Mary's or
whatever they prefer Josh says we're
going to end it after this Josh we'll
end it when I'm winning we'll end it
when I hail the Mary I got to say my
prayers oh no
oh yeah pick a fumble get the fumble
Eric Reed take him with
you God damn it at least someone got 21
seconds Josh we're not leaving until do
your Hail Mary yeah you better Hail Mary
I'll sit everyone up front real stupidly
all right I'll go goal line I'll go
special teams yeah just give one person
back there to defend the play can I do a
can I do a punt return I feel like
you're going to get to me before the H
Mar I'm going to Blitz you yeah I still
feel like I'm going to get hit before if
you don't get this you don't come
Kaepernick's got that speed rating
you're Nimble why is Brandon Lloyd on
his own God I'm also going to foul one
of the players immediately okay Danny is
jamming on the face mask button oh oh
come on you should have used a little
oomph break tackle there I'm time oh
time out yeah see how he did it
emphatically really yeah I'm here to
score more
points thought we discussed this already
yeah we did that's true
hey guys that Blitz worked so good last
time let's just do it
again Floyd golden bar is going to sit
in Stevie we're just going to force to
Stevie I see him Stevie oh there it is
Stevie I'm going to tackle that guy oh
he's going for the corner thanks Danny
sweet dance show me the leg wiggle
Stevie what's that dude's name Stevie
Johnson former Buffalo Bill traded I
think a fourth round for him boom ran up
the necessary there yeah you're lucky he
didn't just jump backwards like he did
last time oh I made sure I run out of
Bounds at the Pyon I made sure for
anyone who's interested in more of
delicious Madden 15 action of course uh
you guys did a stream earlier this
morning yeah that'll be up on the site
it's a long stream with a Madden Pro
Player lots of questions answered lots
of insights into what makes this year's
Madden slightly different than the other
than previous years what some new sort
of tweaks are from the perspective of
someone who plays a crap ton of Madden
cool also I think the review hopefully
today I think is what they're for but if
not today or tomorrow mad today right
yes fantastic all right thanks very much
guys coming on and playing apologies to
everyone all my Minnesota Brethren uh
for uh for for doing a bad losing losing
badly almost hit the camera failing to
score we'll be back in a second we're
going to talk about some P nonsense of
course P Penny Arcade Expo is on H this
weekend this weekend we're going on
Thursday uh we got a bunch of panels on
and we've got a trailer for one of those
panels let's check it out
hello I'm President Snow dwire welcoming
you to the games journalism Hunger Games
MX games journalism is dying which is
why every year we take tributes to
ensure that the strong will survive this
year's districts have paid tribute they
are from IGN Gregory Miller Brian
alond from Giant Bomb Jeffrey Gman
Daniel R from rev three games
Tara Nicholas Robinson from screw attack
Craig skisis sha Bolan from Twitch TV
Jonathan Carnage Justin Flynn and from
games spot Christopher Waters Mary K
Advantage tributes will battle in both
team and solo fights of various couch
competitors of games until a single
district is left The Winner Takes home
the pride of the industry plus a really
[__] trophy we made in an afternoon it's
really [__] so come and support your
tributes 12:30 on Friday at PAX Prime
Sasquatch theater Shout Scream and may
the vods be ever in your
favor
that is the games journalism Hunger
Games MIM on this Friday 12:30 in the
Sasquatch theater a very serious
Endeavor for ab if you in PX and you're
a Gamespot fan please by all means turn
up and pip us up H cuz it sounds like
IGN and giant bomb and screw attack are
going to send a bunch of people our way
from Mar and I need your help yes it's
up to you guys all I'm doing is picking
the games and talking with a terrible
British accent you actually I'm the
trainer you're the trainer train them
yeah you're the
drunk she going to yell at us you're not
even going to be there because you were
setting up our stage right yeah we have
our stage tell Us's I'm going to try to
sneak in but the stage we're going to
have sector
G God sector G it is sector G you got to
explain what sector G is yeah um but we
will be at a restaurant I think like
half a block or down the block I don't
have the address sorry I'm the worst um
but you guys can stop by it's the
Metropole restaurant if you want to
Google it um good job Chris there's
going to be like I think some food some
some beverages uh I hear there going to
be hangover breakfasts there going to be
pancakes and stuff yeah yeah all sorts
of food hanging out with games spot
people playing games winning prizes and
then we're going to do a live show yeah
Saturday and Sunday uh from noon until 2
p.m. am I doing Saturday and you're
doing Sunday correct okay cool because
on Saturday I'm hosting a panel which
panel the fraxis Mega
Panel that's right uh it's civilization
beyond Earth they're going to be like
showing off a bunch of new game play
talking about uh some of the new early
early game and late game stuff in beyond
Earth I got to play it actually earlier
this yesterday and it's really cool so
yeah a bunch of Civ developers and I'll
be talking about that that's going to be
televised on Gamespot I believe or at
least I believe it will be archived on
gamot you'll be able to watch it next
week so if your ad packs come on down
but if you're not you'll be able to
watch it yes ours will be yeah we'll
have it up uh the the games journalism
Hunger Games one will be up like
probably let's say the Monday or Tuesday
um after p uh well I PS is Monday H in
fact I'm doing a second panel with uh
Carlos rizle uh gam spots own prevus
alumni uh about um games you played uh
in your childhood that's on at 12:30 as
well in the Sasquatch theater so same as
the Friday same time the secrets Danny
or do you know I know what games I
played when I was a child as a child are
you going to admit it now or I just
played Lula VB for 15 years do you guys
have that here I have no idea what you
just said Lula virtual babe are you
going to have to bring out that guy idea
what you just said what's that called
the NOP you're nari no it's not Atari
Commodore omega 600 keyboard 64 keyboard
64 but Mary you're not just doing uh The
Hunger Games one you're doing another
one too most important one is The Hunger
Games but in addition to the Hunger
Games I'm also on a panel with uh ladies
in games media surviving and thriving yo
that's correct because not only did we
survive but we we thrived H and you also
have Tara on that one as well so you
guys are going to have to Sprint over
real hard to the games press Ty and I on
both we're GNA be uh we will be at both
uh and I'm excited to have her we also
have Naomi Kyle from IGN um that's naha
from Gamespot she's an executive
producer here Jessica Chobot um and
Megan fanes oh did it you did it I did
great great I've been practicing sweet
yeah so that'll be great yeah got some
great folks on that it's uh that's going
to be fun I'm going to miss it so that's
going to be recorded as well right yes
it will be recorded we'll post that up
later so no no big deal sweet it's all
right T you got to break down this whole
thing right the half this set coming on
the truck some of this stuff is going
luckily we got the truck to come
tomorrow so we wouldn't have to break
our backs today but yeah some of this
stuff Josh included in the back we uh
got to start packing very soon You' been
the packs a bunch of times right Prime
me yeah this will be my second time all
right that's a bunch this is my second
prime my like fifth packs yeah I've been
to East twice but never done never done
prime prime you done it before second
prime yeah you went on your own last
time yes nice were you working that one
um I worked technically it was working
okay work and fun sure I I you know I
wrote it off on my
taxes that's working as far as the
Internal Revenue Service thinks or as
Albert Einstein referred to them the
Great Dragon really yes that's great I
learned that at the sh Science Center
yesterday mother yesterday yes wait you
were you took a day of work to go see a
go to a science museum no that's where
the Civ event was oh that's what you
were at the science museum okay it was
dope we went to the Planetarium and they
had Civ projected on the roof with like
a Starfield in the background that
doesn't sound like work that's excellent
that's job guys all right so that's all
our pack panels uh make sure you're
following us on Twitter for all details
on that if you're heading up to Seattle
and if you are not then we will have
that on gamespot.com next week are we
doing an episode of Lobby next week yes
I heard that's the word
there'll always be a Lobby forever H it
is Cynthia within
earshot yes because we gave away a bunch
of codes for lichon battle mage on PC
and also um Plants Vs zombies Garden
Warfare on PS3 and PS4 I don't have
access to who won them so I don't have a
clue who won them but we will DM you
yeah we'll DM you if you w but
congratulations on winning or if or if
Cynthia is within ear
shot there's some weird bird in
your it's not happening shut it down how
good would it be if we got her to shout
the user names across the office would
be pretty all right I'll be down with
that I'm waiting for the pitter patter
of footsteps I think you're going to be
waiting a while it's coming no I think
we have to close shut the show down
think it's uh St Dam it I'm the only one
went to watch it this is are you what
you saying I don't half life half
marathon probably going to start that in
a couple of minutes you want to hang out
uh thanks everyone who's donated to that
as well we raised almost 7,000 for
project Open Hand by play Half Life yeah
that's awesome I know it's ridiculous we
went for $500 and we raised $500 within
50 minutes of the stream starting
fantastic Dan a bunch of really cool
people uhk you guys donated yeah and you
guys hung out as well last night so yeah
we we've had some fun we have done uh
push-ups for charity squats for charity
wow uh we did Dan uh we turned down for
what we got real drunk two nights in a
row in the office we have been drinking
we ate a full crab yeah we ate a full
crab that was weird that was legit weird
full crab full crab it's not like crabs
are that big you're saying it like I ate
a full pig or something like we ate one
entire it wasn't it wasn't like a dinky
crab the head a giant brain the head was
giant brain I ate the brain there are
many things that crabs have giant brains
are not one of them that's where it kept
it Secrets it was a lot of know good
brain sh about your CRA cholesterol C
Alexis ordered the crab he used one of
those things from orang L he got used
one of those things where you would
basically just get anyone to bring you
editing from any store and they brought
us a freaking crab it was great what
world we live in if you want to watch us
play episode one and episode two and
finish out that ridiculous half marathon
uh it's twitch.tv danani dwire or we'll
have it on gamespot.com chat um after
this bad boy all right we're going to
peace out if you won those codes
apologies you will get a DM about it
thanks so much everyone for watching the
lobby this week uh and we will be back
next week but yeah check us out of
prime